[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
leckere süßspeise die in syrien sehr
beliebt ist aber auch an den ganzen
anderen ländern
wir machen hallo ich bin das ist was
ganz besonderes denn wir haben hier ein
mozzarella gries teig geführt mit der
ganz klassischen mit pudding cremen
namens stars ist total lecker ich zeige
euch aber trotzdem gleich noch eine
alternative und gesüßt wir das ganze wie
immer mit zuckersirup und mit dem
starten jetzt auch und zwar brauchen wir
dafür auch nur drei zutaten wasser
zucker und ein bisschen zitronensaft ich
sage jetzt damit indem ich wasser und
zucker in meinem kopf gebe und dass
einmal aufkochen lassen
ihr dürft ihr auch gerne mal umrühren
damit sich der zucker richtig schön
verbindet man das einmal aufkochen und
dann zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht
sobald das zuckerwasser aufkocht geben
wir zitronensaft mit ihnen lassen dass
fünf minuten lang köcheln soll ich mir
das ganze ein bisschen dicker und dann
ist der zucker sirup eigentlich auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
für den milchprodukten benötigen wir mit
schlagsahne puderzucker speisestärke und
was auch ganz wichtig ist rosenwasser
und orangenblüten wasser bevor ich den
herd jetzt anmache geben wir zuallererst
alle zutaten in den topf grün das einmal
gut um und dann kochen wir das erst auf
so das ganze ist jetzt klümpchen frei
und an der stelle geben wir auch
rosenwasser und orangenblüten wasser mit
hinzu so unscheinbar aber so lecker in
dem ganzen pudding also verzichtet da
auf keinen fall darauf ihr müsst um den
kran geben dann habt ihr richtig dieses
orient feeling so und jetzt kochen wir
das einmal auf aber bitte ständig rühren
denn ihr wisst ja milch ist einfach so
ein kandidat der brend einfach an und
deswegen lass uns einfach ständig rühren
damit euch das nicht passieren kann
sobald euer pudding einmal auf koch
liegt er auch sofort ein
und dann müssen ihnen einmal uffeln in
eine schale
so dem pudding wissen wir jetzt noch mit
frischhaltefolie abdecken und zwar
direkt auf der oberfläche sind habt ihr
so eine schöne haut und das braucht
einfach kein mensch so einmal schön auf
der oberfläche abdecken und jetzt muss
der pudding vollständig auskühlen
für den teig benötigen wir mozzarella
wasser außerdem weichweizen krise und
rosenwasser mozzarella schneiden geht's
aber zuallererst in kleine stücke denn
müssen bis er gleich schmelzen und in
kleine stücke lässt es sich einfach viel
leichter schmelzen
und jetzt geben wir den kleinen
geschnittenen mozzarella in unseren topf
am besten entweder einen beschichteten
funktioniert dann einfach besser und
unser wasser gehen wir auch schon mit
dazu und ebenfalls unser rosenwasser
jetzt habe ich den herd eingeschaltet
und zwar nicht die höchste stufe dann
kann es nämlich ganz leicht passieren
dass euch das ganze anbrennt wenn ihr
zum beispiel neun stufen habe dann halt
einfach die stufe 7 und dann seid ihr da
eigentlich am besten mit und jetzt wird
das ganze unter ständigem rühren
geschmolzen
jetzt hat sich der mozzarella komplett
zu so einem schönen weichen klumpen
gebildet an schönen weichen klumpen ihr
wisst was ich meine
weil jedenfalls könnt ihr das nicht so
verbinden dass die flüssigkeit ebenfalls
mit dem klumpen vereint wird es
unmöglich dafür sorgt nämlich jetzt
unser gries ich wollte noch mal zeigen
wie lecker dass aus den ich weiß nicht
ist das krank dass ich da am liebsten
reinbeißen würde man sieht so lecker aus
jedenfalls gehen wir jetzt immer so
stückchenweise rechner und sein wie es
dazu es bloß nicht alles auf einmal
sondern jemanden nur so prof
[Musik]
so unser teig ist damit fertig und der
ist noch warm ja aber wir müssen ihnen
sofort weiter verarbeiten
falls setzt der fall sein sollte dass
irgend jemand an der tür schellt oder e
guard nicht könnt und fünf minuten pause
braucht dann lasst ihn im warmen topf
damit er auch nicht fest und hart werden
kann oder beauftragt eure kinder eure
kleine schwester bilder damit dass die
ab und zu mal umrühren so ich mache
jetzt alles bereit ruhe in den
zuckersirup und die füllung und dann
zeige ich euch den fast letzten schritt
so bevor wir uns jetzt den teig auf
unsere sauberen arbeitsfläche ausbreiten
gehen wir noch drei vier esslöffel von
unserem lauwarm oder kalten zuckersirup
auf die arbeitsfläche
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmen wir uns den teig und
breiten ihn rechteckig aus und zwar am
besten so dünn wie möglich sie zu dass
ihr euch nicht reißt aber versucht es
einfach so dünn wie möglich auszurollen
und jetzt seht ja auch warum wir keinen
zucker im teig haben denn wer dafür
unseren berühmt-berüchtigten zuckersirup
also ihr seht mein tag ist alles andere
als rechteckig nobody's perfect aber
egal ich verspreche euch das endergebnis
wir trotzdem richtig schön aussehen so
jetzt schneide ich den tag hier einmal
schön gerade ab damit wir einen schönen
anfang haben die reste natürlich nicht
wegwerfen die fesche ich welche sowas
von
und dann nehmen wir uns unsere füllungen
haben sie schmecken auch über zur
füllung das ist jetzt der kalt gewordene
pudding so und dann kann man den ja auch
locker mit den händen so ein bisschen
verteilen um so ein bisschen auseinander
ziehen nimmt er am besten solche füllung
wie ihr am liebsten mit
[Musik]
so die pudding füllung ist jetzt auf den
teig ich habe das auch schon mal gesehen
dass man das gap streich und dann auf
freut aber ich habe das gefühl so kriegt
man einfach mehr füllung in diesem tag
und jetzt soll ich das ganze einmal auf
[Musik]
und dann können wir die erste rolle
schon mal an der seite entlang
abschneiden
so jetzt nehmen wir uns unser
schneidebrett und ein sehr scharfes
messer nehmen wir uns die rolle packen
die auf das schnell gedreht und dann
schneiden wir uns die stückchen ab
das unschöne ende einmal wegschneiden
und dann mag ich es am liebsten wenn man
das schräg schneidet ich finde dass die
optik dann ein bisschen schöner ist
die erste portion ist jetzt fertig und
gleich wieder natürlich noch zuckersirup
darauf getan dass dekoriert aber ich hab
ich ja versprochen ich zeig euch noch
eine alternative zu den mit pudding
falls ihr euch irgendwie zu aufwendig
sein sollte was aber eigentlich gar
nicht ist aber ihr könnt auch mascarpone
nehmen oder rekord habe zum beispiel
mascarpone ich befürchte jetzt aber
komplett mit dem mit problemen ist
einfach unglaublich lecker schmeckt und
dass auch meine empfehlung an euch also
versucht gerne unbedingt mit dem
mächtigen
[Musik]
unsere hallo ich bin sieben sind jetzt
fast fertig es fehlt nur noch die süße
und die bekommen wir ausschließlich
durch den zucker sirup und später
dekorieren wir das ganze noch ich habe
mich hier jetzt ein bisschen mascarpone
in meinem spritzbeutel gefüllt mit einer
kleinen stern tolle dran aber das muss
natürlich nicht sein könnte auch einfach
ein teelöffel nehmen und das ganze wir
traditionell noch mit orangenblüten
dekoriert aber die bekommt man so schwer
her und deswegen nämlich einfach grüne
pistazien
wir haben hier einiges vom teig übrig
und das dürft ihr auf keinen fall
wegschmeißen der schmeckt so lecker
also nehmt euch den übrig gebliebenen
teile schneidet ihn so kleine stückchen
und dann gebt ihr einfach zuckersirup
drüber und dann kann man das mit der
gabel so noch essen
übrigens halten sie im kühlschrank mit
einer frischhaltefolie gut verpackt drei
bis vier tage und ich empfehle euch
wärmstens nach zu machen falls er auch
mal eure freunde überraschen möchte oder
einfach mal zeigen möchte jetzt schaut
mal syrische spezialität das muss
einfach mal probiert werden
dann macht es gerne nach ich schreibe
euch wie immer unten in die info box
sieht ganz genauen mengenangaben freue
mich natürlich über eure fotos und ich
bin gerade bei diesem rezept total
gespannt auf eure fotos gerne mit dem
hashtag s kitchen auf instagram falls
sie mit dortmund nicht folgt schnell
nachholen hier sowieso und dann sage ich
bis zum nächsten mal aufwies kitchen
tschüss
[Musik]